From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And each week on our show we choose a theme, invite writers and performers of all kinds to do stories on that theme. And, usually, somewhere near the top of the show, I tell you what the theme is and give you a little road map of what's coming up in the hour. But I think that today, it's going to be more interesting if we just start right in on the first act and let things unfold for a while before I give it a name, before I tell you what the theme is.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会选定一个主题，邀请各类作家和表演者讲述关于该主题的故事。通常在节目开始时，我会告诉大家主题是什么，并简单介绍一下这一个小时的内容安排。但我觉得今天，直接进入第一幕，让故事先展开一会儿，等会儿再揭晓主题会更有趣。
So our first story is by Dael Orlandersmith. It's originally from her Obie-award winning show, Beauty's Daughters, and was recorded at a variety show here in Chicago, called Millie's Orchid Show.
我们的第一个故事来自黛尔·奥兰德史密斯。它源自她曾获奥比奖的表演秀《美人的女儿们》，录制于芝加哥的一场名为“米莉兰花秀”的综艺节目中。
Before we begin this story, two quick caveats. Number one, some of the language might not be suitable for younger listeners. Though, as you'll hear, we've beeped out the nastiest words. And, number two-- and usually I would never point something like this out-- you need to know that Dael is a woman, an African-American woman. And I point this out because, If I didn't, you wouldn't be able to enjoy what the audience in the theater with her gets to enjoy, which is the pleasure of watching her complete transformation into this loudmouthed, white guy. So here's Dael Orlandersmith.
在开始这个故事前，有两个小小的提醒。第一，其中的部分语言可能不太适合未成年听众，不过你们会听到，我们已经把最难听的词给消音了。第二——通常我绝不会指出这一点——你们需要知道黛尔是一位女性，一位非裔美国女性。我之所以要说出来，是因为如果不说，你们就无法享受到现场观众所能体验到的乐趣，那就是看她如何彻底变身为一个满嘴粗话的白人男性。那么，有请黛尔·奥兰德史密斯。
Hey! Ah! Jerry! How you doin', buddy? How you doin'? Lorraine, you lookin' good honey. You lookin' so fine. Lenny! How's it going? All right.
嘿！啊！杰瑞！哥们儿，你好吗？最近怎么样？洛林，你看上去真不错，甜心。你看起来真棒。莱尼！最近怎么样？挺好的。
Johnny Black, nectar of the gods. Oh, man. I tell you, Len, today was [BLEEP]. Yeah, yeah. I know every day is [BLEEP]. But today was really [BLEEP], you know? So [BLEEP] busy.
强尼·布莱克，上帝的甘露啊。哦，伙计。我说真的，莱尼，今天简直太[消音]了。没错，没错。我知道每一天都[消音]，但今天真的太[消音]了，你知道吧？忙得[消音]要死。
See, everybody I know who works in the fish market-- because my clothes are gettin' [BLEEP] ruined here-- everybody I know who works in the fish market, their clothes are [BLEEP] up.
你看，我认识的每个在鱼市工作的人——因为我的衣服在这儿都被[消音]毁了——我认识的在鱼市工作的人，衣服都[消音]烂了。
And I tell you, Len, I can't stand the thought of goin' home right now. I just can't. Theresa's gettin' fatter and fatter. It ain't 'cause she's pregnant because I don't touch this bitch.
我跟你说，莱尼，我现在一想到回家就受不了。真的受不了。特蕾莎变得越来越胖了。不是因为她怀孕了，因为我根本碰都不碰这个婊子。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Well, what? What? I'm cold for saying that? Why am I cold? Lenny, let me explain something. No, please wait. No, please, please listen to me. Lenny, I'm 31 years old. I'm married 12 years. I got seven kids. I'm a young man. I'm [BLEEP] trapped. And TT's the laziest bitch in the world. No, no, hear me out. Here she is, 28 years old, looking 50. The problem is? The problem is I married too quick.
怎么？什么？就因为我说了那个，我就冷血了？我怎么就冷血了？莱尼，让我解释一下。不，等等。不，求你了，听我说。莱尼，我今年31岁，结婚12年，有7个孩子。我还年轻啊。我被[消音]困住了。而TT是世界上最懒的婊子。不，不，听我说完。看看她，28岁，看起来像50岁。问题是什么？问题是我结婚太早了。
My cousin, Jimmy, says to me, he says, "Anthony, don't get married so quick. You's two are young. Go out and get laid. Have a pisser." But, of course, I don't listen, right? I don't listen. So this is what I am today.
我表哥吉米跟我说：“安东尼，别结那么早婚。你们两个都还年轻。出去快活快活，喝个痛快。”但当然，我没听，对吧？我没听。所以这就是我现在的下场。
Come here. I wanna tell you something. Come here. I wanna tell you something. Come here [BLEEP]. Don't [BLEEP] with me. Come over here. Come over here.
过来，我想告诉你点事。过来。我想告诉你点事。过来，[消音]。别跟我[消音]胡闹。过来这儿。过来这儿。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I met this chick at my friend Manno's wedding. Yeah, it's a black chick. Yeah, right. Anthony Mancuso. Right. Same [BLEEP] guy from Red Hook. Right. Same guy. Right. He's been in here with me a few times. Right. He lives on 36th Avenue now, in Bensonhurst. Right. It's the same guy. Yeah. Yeah! It's the same [BLEEP] guy. Yeah, it's the same guy.
我在我朋友曼诺的婚礼上遇到了这个妞。没错，是个黑人妞。没错，就是这样。安东尼·曼库索。没错。就是红钩区那个[消音]家伙。没错。同一个人。没错。他跟我一起来过几次。没错。他现在住在本森赫斯特的第36大道。没错。就是那家伙。是啊。是啊！就是同一个[消音]家伙。没错，就是他。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So, anyway, you know, we're at the reception, right? And TT's talking to Manno's wife, Gail, with the rest of the Cusonettes, right? They're sitting there. They're talkin', "Nah, nah, nah, nah nah." And Manno's wife, Gail, is no prize either, [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. So anyway, this black chick-- Diane, her name is, right-- is sittin' over to the side, right?
反正，我们在招待会上，对吧？TT正在和曼诺的老婆盖尔以及其他那帮女人聊天。她们坐在那儿，在那儿唠叨。曼诺的老婆盖尔也不是什么好货，[听不清]。反正，那个黑人妞——她叫黛安——坐在旁边，对吧？
So I look over at her, smile. She smiles back. Then I notice that she's big, not fat, big. In proportion, the way TT used to be, right? So I go over to her and I say, "You know, I really think you're good-lookin'. And they really need to get rid of words like Nigger and Guinea. Do you know why? Because I wanna put my tongue in your mouth." She gets mad.
于是我看了她一眼，笑了笑。她也回笑了。然后我注意到她很丰满，不是胖，是丰满。身材很匀称，就像TT以前那样，对吧？于是我走过去说：“你知道吗，我觉得你真的挺好看。那些‘黑鬼’或者‘意大利佬’之类的词真的该废除了。你知道为什么吗？因为我想把我的舌头伸进你的嘴里。”她生气了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
She says, "Let me tell you something. The only reason why you came over here is because I'm the only black person at this wedding. Well, guess what? I don't have a problem with that. You do. So do yourself a favor. Get out of my face before I hurt you."
她说：“我告诉你，你过来是因为我是这场婚礼上唯一的黑人。好吧，猜怎么着？我对此没意见。你有意见。所以帮你自己个忙，在我动手揍你之前赶紧滚远点。”
Now I'm standing there [BLEEP] slammed, right? So I say, "Listen. Listen. Come here. Listen. I don't care how big you are. Woman or not, you hit me, you're dead," right? Then she says, "First of all, my being a woman is not the issue because I'm more man than you'll ever be and more woman than you'll ever know."
现在我站在那儿被[消音]怼得哑口无言，对吧？于是我说：“听着。听着。过来。听着。我才不在乎你多大个儿。管你是男是女，你敢打我，你就死定了。”然后她说：“首先，我是女人这一点不是重点，因为我比你更像个男人，也比你更了解女人。”
[WHOOPS]
[起哄声]
"Second of all, technically, I know I can't whip you because you're still a man. But, if you lay one finger on me, I'll give you such a fight you'll wish to God you stayed home today. In other words, my name is pain. I will inflict. Now, do you really wanna [BLEEP] with me?"
“其次，技术上讲，我知道我打不过你，因为你毕竟是个男人。但是，如果你敢动我一根手指，我会让你后悔今天来到这儿。换句话说，我的名字叫痛苦。我会让你生不如死。现在，你真的想跟我[消音]过不去吗？”
[WHOOPS]
[起哄声]
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
So now, you know, like, I'm quiet, right? And I'm also scared outta my mind. Now, part of me wants to give her a smack, and another part of me's in love, Lenny, she's so [BLEEP] tough, right? So I say, "Rocky! Hey! Hey! Hey! Hey, Rocky. I'm sorry, baby. I apologize. Come with me to the bar to get a drink," right?
现在，你看，我安静了，对吧？而且我吓得要死。一方面我想扇她一巴掌，另一方面我爱上她了，莱尼，她简直[消音]太强悍了，对吧？所以我说：“洛奇！嘿！嘿！嘿！嘿，洛奇。对不起，宝贝。我道歉。跟我去吧台喝一杯，好吗？”
So we go to the bar. We go to the bar, right? So I say, "Diane, let me order you a rum and Coke, because I know that blacks and Ricas like that, right?" She gets mad again, right? And she says, "Order me Stoli, rocks, lime garnish, and stop being an asshole." So now I know I'm in love, right? Right.
于是我们去了吧台。我们去了吧台，对吧？然后我说：“黛安，让我给你点杯朗姆可乐，因为我知道黑人和拉丁裔喜欢那个，对吧？”她又生气了。她说：“给我点杯斯托利伏特加，加冰，加一片青柠，别再当个混蛋了。”现在我知道我恋爱了，对吧？没错。
So we go to the bar. We're hangin' out. We're talkin', "Yadda, yadda yadda." And the DJ starts playing. I give you one [BLEEP] guess, man. One guess. There you go, baby, Sinatra, Jerry Vale. I swear on my mother, every Guinea wedding, Sinatra, Jerry Vale, right? So then, since all of us are in our '30s, the DJ started playing disco because that's what we danced to when we were kids, and [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
所以我们在吧台闲逛，聊天。然后DJ开始放音乐了。我让你猜[消音]一次，伙计。猜一次。没错了，宝贝，辛纳屈，杰瑞·维尔。我敢对我妈发誓，每个意大利婚礼上都是辛纳屈和杰瑞·维尔，对吧？然后，因为我们都30多岁了，DJ开始放迪斯科，因为那是我们小时候跳的舞。
And I asked Diane would she like to dance. And she says, "No." She hates disco, likes rock, old R&B and jazz. I said, "Oh, my God." I said, "What? You like jazz?" So she said, "Yeah." Lenny, I swear on my [BLEEP] mother, for the next three hours we're talkin' jazz.
我问黛安愿不愿意跳舞。她说“不”。她讨厌迪斯科，喜欢摇滚、老式R&B和爵士乐。我说：“天呐。什么？你喜欢爵士？”她说：“是啊。”莱尼，我敢对我[消音]妈发誓，接下来的三个小时我们一直在聊爵士乐。
You see, I don't know whether you know this, but I was a major jazz fan, man. I used play. I used to play horn. I was playing both sax and trumpet. And my [BLEEP] record collection, man, I had Cannonball Adderley. I had Miles and Prez, you know? See, jazz, at that time, man, was like so a part of me, you know? But I can't touch it any more. You know what I'm saying?
你看，我不知道你知不知道，但我曾是个超级爵士迷。我以前玩过。我玩过圆号。我萨克斯和小号都吹。还有我那[消音]唱片收藏，伙计，我有加农炮艾德里的，我有迈尔斯和普雷兹的，你知道吧？那时候，爵士乐是我生命的一部分。但我现在碰不了了，你知道我在说什么吗？
So Diane is a poet, you know? And I never knew a poet before. And she was talkin' about, maybe, that I could pick up my horn again, and maybe she could write lyrics. And God, I swear to God, Lenny. This woman is so [BLEEP] beautiful to me now, right? And I'm thinking well, yeah. Maybe, yeah, you know? I could pick up the horn again. You know? And she's just talkin' and talkin'. And I swear she's the most beautiful thing I ever seen, right?
黛安是个诗人，你知道吧？我以前从没认识过诗人。她谈到说，也许我可以重新拿起号，也许她可以写歌词。天呐，我发誓，莱尼。这个女人现在在我眼里简直[消音]太美了，对吧？我在想，也许吧，真的，你知道吗？我可以重新拿起号。你知道吗？她一直在说个不停。我发誓她是我见过最美的东西，对吧？
And she tells me, she says-- I'm gonna sound [BLEEP] queer saying this to you, all right-- but she says, "Anthony, when you talk about music, your face becomes beautiful." Yeah, she said that to me, Lenny. She also called me a pain in the ass. But she said, when I talk music, I become beautiful.
她告诉我——对你说这话我听起来像个[消音]怪胎——她说：“安东尼，当你谈论音乐时，你的脸变得很美。”是啊，她对我说了那话，莱尼。她还叫我混蛋，但她说，当我在谈论音乐时，我变得很美。
So, Lenny, all of a sudden-- wait a minute. Wait. I don't want nobody to hear this, right? All of a sudden, Lenny, sittin' there, talking about all these people that I liked in jazz, I felt like crying because I'm not going to be able to touch it again. And nobody ever saw that in me before, you know? Nobody.
所以，莱尼，突然间——等等。等等。我不想让任何人听到，对吧？突然间，莱尼，坐在那儿，谈论着我喜欢的那些爵士乐手，我想哭，因为我知道我再也回不去那段时光了。从来没人看穿过我这一面，你知道吧？从来没有。
So, anyway, we're talking. And she's really hot, you know? And I wanted to get outside because I was dying to ask for her phone number, right? Seconds later, TT walks out with the kids. "Anthony, me and the kids are ready to go home. Now!" Diane looks at me like I'm [BLEEP] crazy, right? TT's standin' there looking like a [BLEEP] whale. What the [BLEEP] can I do? Bada bing. Bada bang. I introduce them to each other. Diane says, "Pleased to meet you. I'm outta here. I'm doing the slide."
反正，我们在聊天。她真的很火辣，你知道吧？我想去外面，因为我迫不及待想问她的电话号码，对吧？几秒钟后，TT带着孩子走了出来。“安东尼，我和孩子们准备回家了。现在！”黛安看着我，像看个[消音]疯子一样，对吧？TT站在那儿看起来像头[消音]鲸鱼。我[消音]能干什么？啪嗒一声。我把她们互相介绍了一下。黛安说：“很高兴见到你。我先走了。”
That night, I take TT home, right? And dig this. Dig this. I go down in my basement, right? And, for the first time in five years, I pick up my sax. And it feels so [BLEEP] good to hold it, you know? Then I put it to my mouth, and with every note I can taste, feel, Diane. See, she's all over this [BLEEP] horn.
那天晚上，我把TT送回家，对吧？注意听，注意听。我走进地下室，五年里第一次拿起了我的萨克斯。那种感觉真他妈[消音]好，你知道吗？然后我把它贴到嘴边，每一个音符里我都能尝到、感觉到黛安。你看，她简直就在这支[消音]号上。
Then I put the sax down, open my eyes, and it dawns on me I ain't going nowhere. I ain't going nowhere. But I could always do another shot of Johnny Black, right, babe? Well, wah, don't worry about me. I won't get junked. I can't. I gotta go to work tomorrow. But, you know, this is my time now, right? Just let me sit here for a few minutes, all right? I tell you what, my time. I'll go in a little while. I'll go in a little while.
然后我放下萨克斯，睁开眼睛，我意识到我哪儿也去不了。我哪儿也去不了。但我总是能再来一杯强尼·布莱克，对吧，宝贝？好了，哎，别担心我。我不会堕落的。我不能。我明天还得上班。但是，你知道，现在是我的时间了，对吧？就让我在这儿坐几分钟，好吗？我跟你说，这是我的时间。我一会儿就去。一会儿就去。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[MUSIC PLAYING - ORIGINAL SAX SOLO BY KEN VANDERMARK]
[音乐播放 - 肯·范德马克原创萨克斯独奏]
Ken Vandermark on the sax. This story was by Dael Orlandersmith. And this brings us to today's theme, which is people who come alive for music, people who live for music, even though, for most of them, they'll never get very far with music. All our stories today, on today's show, are people about whom you could say--
萨克斯手肯·范德马克。这个故事由黛尔·奥兰德史密斯带来。这也把我们引向今天的主题：那些为音乐而生的人，那些靠音乐活着的人，尽管对他们中的大多数人来说，他们永远无法在音乐道路上走得很远。今天节目中的所有故事，都是关于这样的人——
When you talk about music, your face becomes beautiful.
当你谈论音乐时，你的脸变得很美。
That's right. In our program today Act Two-- we just heard Act One-- Act Two will be a brother who struggles to be a star. Act Three, Choosing Fandom. Act Four, a life in music without fame or fortune.
没错。在今天的节目中，第二幕——我们刚听完第一幕——第二幕将讲述一个挣扎着想成为明星的兄弟。第三幕，选择成为粉丝。第四幕，没有名利伴随的音乐人生。
So we are now at Act Two, for those of you who are keeping careful, careful score. I know there's so many of you who are. Act Two is a story about somebody who decided to follow his dream, about being a musician. And, you know, usually, when you hear stories about somebody chasing a dream like this, stories about rock stars or Olympic athletes, or writers, or painters, or basically anybody who had to get out there and follow that star, follow that dream, we don't hear how crushingly hard it is for the overwhelming majority of them. And in the middle of the story, usually, you don't wonder is this worth it?
所以，对于那些一直在仔细计分的听众，我们现在进入第二幕。我知道你们很多人都在听。第二幕是一个关于决定追求音乐梦想的人的故事。通常，当你听到关于追逐梦想的故事，关于摇滚明星、奥运选手、作家、画家，或者任何那些出去追求星星和梦想的人，我们通常听不到这对绝大多数人来说是多么毁灭性的困难。在故事中间，你通常不会怀疑：这值得吗？
Well, the story you're about to hear does not have that shortcoming. You definitely wonder. The story you're about to hear was produced by Jay Allison with Dan Gediman. Dan is the one who narrates the story.
那么，你们即将听到的这个故事没有这种缺陷。你肯定会怀疑的。这个故事由杰·艾利森和丹·盖迪曼制作，由丹担任讲述人。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "FALL IN LOVE" BY ALEX JONES SINGING TOM JONES]
[音乐播放 - 亚历克斯·琼斯演唱的《陷入爱河》]
That's not Tom Jones. It's my brother, Alex Jones. And that's not his real name. His real name is Mark Gediman.
那不是汤姆·琼斯。是我弟弟，亚历克斯·琼斯。那也不是他的真名。他真名叫马克·盖迪曼。
You know, my real last name is Gediman, G- E- D, as in David, I- M- A- N. You know, I'm proud of the name. But, as far as show biz is concerned, it can't be spelled.
你知道，我的真姓是盖迪曼，G-E-D-I-M-A-N。我对这个姓很自豪。但就演艺圈而言，它太难拼了。
My brother's middle name is Alex. He bumped it up to the front.
我弟弟的中间名是亚历克斯。他把它挪到了前面。
But I like Alex. Alexes work. There aren't too many Alexes that are big these days, so I'm sticking with that name. It's very catchy because people always remember Alex.
但我喜欢亚历克斯。亚历克斯这个名字好使。现在没多少大牌叫亚历克斯，所以我坚持用这个名字。它很抓耳，因为人们总是能记住亚历克斯。
For a while, when he was in this rock band in the late '70s, he called himself Alex Space. But that's another story. For the past five years it's been Jones, Alex Jones.
有一段时间，当他在70年代末参加那个摇滚乐队时，他管自己叫“亚历克斯空间”。但那是另一个故事了。过去五年里，他一直叫琼斯，亚历克斯·琼斯。
I had a jones for singing. I had an addiction.
我有一种唱歌的瘾。我上瘾了。
That's pretty much the truth. My brother has had a jones for singing for just about as long as he's been alive. All he ever wanted to do is make music, to sing for people.
这基本是实话。我弟弟从他记事起就对唱歌上瘾。他想要的只是创作音乐，为人们唱歌。
The Kiwanis group, the Knights of Columbus, the Lions Club, the Elks, the Sons of Italy, you name it, if there's one of those, I've been there.
基瓦尼会、哥伦布骑士会、狮子会、麋鹿会、意大利之子会，不管是什么组织，只要有的地方，我都去过。
My brother sang constantly in our house when we were growing up. He always wanted to be a rock star or the next great soul singer. Once he was out on his own, he sang everywhere he could. And he still does, anywhere he can find an audience to appreciate him.
我弟弟小时候在家里一直在唱歌。他总是想成为摇滚明星或是下一位伟大的灵魂乐歌手。他独立生活后，能去的地方都唱。现在也一样，只要能找到欣赏他的听众，他就会唱。
--the Jerry Lewis Telethon. I've done schools. I've done colleges. I've done arts exhibition and whatever-- they also have cows and things like that, you know, one of those-- and, basically, anybody that'll have me, you know? Yeah, Tom gets around.
——杰瑞·路易斯马拉松慈善节目。我去过学校、学院，参加过艺术展之类的——有些地方还有奶牛之类的，你知道，那种——基本上，任何人愿意让我去，我就去，你知道吗？是的，汤姆经常到处跑。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
My brother's been in countless rock, blues, and R&B bands over the years. But, these days, he's mostly hired as a Tom Jones impersonator. He does that by night, though. During the day, he holds down a straight job.
这些年来，我弟弟参加过无数摇滚、蓝调和R&B乐队。但这些天，他主要是被聘为汤姆·琼斯的模仿者。不过，他是在晚上做这些。白天，他有一份正经工作。
You know, it's tough to tell people, your co-workers, I'm going to be Tom Jones, particularly when I've been trying for the last few years to develop an image of this-- I've been working as a computer analyst-- and developing this image as this kind of conservative nerd-type. And I've totally, totally blown it.
你知道，要告诉同事“我要去做汤姆·琼斯”很难，尤其是当我过去几年一直在树立一种形象——我一直做计算机分析师——树立这种保守书呆子的形象。我把这一切全搞砸了。
[SINGING - "FALL IN LOVE" AS TOM JONES]
[演唱 - 作为汤姆·琼斯的《陷入爱河》]
My brother performs with a revue called The Hall of Fame Superstars. There's a Patsy Cline, an Elton John, Buddy Holly, Roy Orbison. And then my brother closes the show as Tom Jones.
我弟弟在一个叫“名人堂超级巨星”的剧团演出。里面有帕特西·克莱恩、埃尔顿·约翰、巴迪·霍利、罗伊·奥比森。最后由我弟弟作为汤姆·琼斯压轴出场。
Singing as Tom Jones is very similar to the way that I naturally sing. We have a lot in common. But I've gotten to the point where I'm hitting notes and doing things that are beyond the scope of what he did.
唱汤姆·琼斯的歌和我自然的唱歌方式很像。我们有很多共同点。但我已经达到了那种能唱出更高音符、做到他原本范围之外事情的程度。
My brother is nothing, if not confident, at least on the surface. He thinks positive and has an uncanny, almost, overconfidence. It's an amazing quality, really, even unsettling.
我弟弟如果说有什么特点，那就是自信，至少在表面上。他心态积极，有一种离奇的、近乎过度的自信。这真的很惊人，甚至让人感到不安。
My brother's 43, not married, doesn't have kids. He's had a lot of girlfriends, but he doesn't have a steady one now. These days, he's living at home with my parents in Massachusetts.
我弟弟今年43岁，没结婚，没孩子。他有过很多女朋友，但现在没有稳定的。这些天，他住在马萨诸塞州我父母的家里。
Why don't we go to the music room?
我们要不去音乐室？
All right.
好的。
--for a little bit to get out of the way.
——避开一会儿。
Growing up, we had a room in the house we called the music room.
成长过程中，我们家里有一个房间叫音乐室。
Now it looks a whole lot different.
现在看起来大不相同了。
That's where my brother and I talked the last time I was home visiting.
这就是我上次回家探亲时，我和我弟弟聊天的地方。
There was a Scott amplifier.
那里有一个斯科特放大器。
Right. Right in the corner here.
对。就在角落里。
Yeah, and in the corner here was a very large, professional turntable, which had come right from a radio station. And I forget what the brand of that one was.
是的，角落里还有一个非常专业的大唱片机，直接从广播电台弄来的。我忘了是什么牌子了。
Rek-O-Kut.
Rek-O-Kut。
Rek-O-Kut, yeah. But it was a top-of-the-line.
Rek-O-Kut，是的。那可是顶级的。
But, yeah, this was a great room, great atmosphere. And you walked in this room and there were little musical notes bouncing all around it. And it was a place where we could just go in and play around and make believe you're the star.
但没错，这是个很棒的房间，氛围很好。你走进这个房间，到处都是跳动的音符。这是一个我们可以进去假装自己是明星的地方。
[SINGING] Come on, baby. Oh, let's loop-a-loo. She's a ha-hum, baby. Nothin' she can do. She's my little baby. Little Latin Lupe Loo.
[演唱] 来吧，宝贝。噢，让我们摇摆吧。她是位……没什么能难倒她。她是我的小宝贝。小小的拉丁女孩。
This is a tape of my brother pretending to be a star, recorded on my family's old Grundig tape recorder back around 1966. My parents put a lot of insulation in the walls of the music room, so my brother could really scream.
这是我弟弟假装成明星的一盘磁带，大约1966年在我家那台旧Grundig录音机上录的。我父母在音乐室的墙壁里加了很多隔音材料，这样我弟弟就可以尽情地尖叫。
The entertainers who really are memorable and who've stand the test of time, a great deal of them have tremendous screams. So I've always thought that screaming was essential to someone who-- not necessarily in the popular music idiom. But, in anything that had any kind of edge or soul to it, there's got to be a scream there, somewhere. And the whole reason is the same reason. It's a expression of the most inner, primal feelings.
那些真正令人难忘、经得起时间考验的艺人，很多人都有惊人的尖叫功底。所以我一直认为尖叫对一个人来说是必不可少的——并不一定是在流行音乐习语中。但在任何有某种底色或灵魂的东西中，某处必须得有一声尖叫。而其原因都是一样的。那是内心深处原始情感的一种表达。
Wow! Hey! Oh!
哇！嘿！噢！
This is the room where my brother began studying the great rhythm and blues singers, people like Al Green, Little Richard, Otis Redding, James Brown, and Tom Jones, who my brother thinks brings them all together.
这就是我弟弟开始研究那些伟大的节奏蓝调歌手的房间，像艾尔·格林、小理查德、奥蒂斯·雷丁、詹姆斯·布朗，还有汤姆·琼斯，我弟弟认为他把这些人都融合在了一起。
Just at the beginning of What's New Pussycat, he goes, "What's!"
就在《What's New Pussycat》开头，他喊道：“What's!”
Right.
对。
See? Now, you're getting, now, right there with the what;s, you've got James Brown, "Wow!" You know?
你看？就在那个What's里，你有詹姆斯·布朗的“Wow！”你知道吧？
Right.
对。
And then you got Wilson Pickett, "Ah-Ow!" And then you got Ray Charles, "Mm, Oh!" You know? And then you've got like, "Yeah!" Then you get, "Uh!" and, "Ah!" and, "Hey! Hoy! Ah! Ah-oh! Ew-oh! Oh! Mm! Mm! What's!" See? So that's there, you know?
然后你有威尔逊·皮克特的“Ah-Ow！”然后你有雷·查尔斯的“Mm, Oh！”你知道吧？然后你有那种“Yeah！”然后是“Uh！”和“Ah！”还有“Hey! Hoy! Ah! Ah-oh! Ew-oh! Oh! Mm! Mm! What's!”你看？这就是那种感觉，你知道吧？
I remember the first time I ever saw my brother perform. My parents took me to see him at a high school variety show when I was still in elementary school.
我还记得我第一次见到我弟弟表演。在我上小学的时候，父母带我去高中综艺晚会看他表演。
Now, nobody knew that I could sing. But there was a band, the Blood, Sweat & Tears, and the first version of them with Al Cooper. And there was a song on there called, "I Love You More Than You'll Ever Know", which is a real bluesy ballad. And I used to sing that over, and over, and over again in this music room. And so I ended up singing it.
当时没人知道我能唱歌。但是有一个叫“血、汗与泪”的乐队，是艾尔·库珀参与的第一版。里面有一首歌叫《I Love You More Than You'll Ever Know》，那是一首非常蓝调的慢歌。我过去在那间音乐室一遍又一遍地唱这首歌。所以最后我就唱了这首。
It was my first real performance, as me, in front of a stage, being the performer, like the Elvis or something. And I can remember having this silky shirt on. And I probably had my ID bracelet hanging. And I opened up my collar a little. And it was quite an experience, as I recall. And I think I did fairly well. I still do. I really sold it out, you know? I really started screaming there at the end.
那是我第一次真正地在舞台前作为表演者出现，像猫王什么的。我记得我穿着一件丝绸衬衫。我的身份证手链可能也挂在外面。我把领口解开了点。回想起来，那真是一次难得的经历。我觉得我演得还不错。我真的卖力了，你知道吗？在结尾的时候我真的开始尖叫了。
I remember, by the end of the number, your shirt was virtually half off or something. That was my recollection. I was very impressed. I'm sure it was the first time I ever saw you perform.
我记得在曲子结束时，你的衬衫几乎都掉了一半。那是我的记忆。我印象很深。我敢肯定那是第一次看你演出。
I don't even remember that you were there.
我甚至都不记得你在场。
Oh, I was absolutely there.
噢，我绝对在场。
Yeah?
是吗？
Yeah, absolutely there. And I remember that very well. And mostly, of course, I remember you.
是的，绝对在。我记忆犹新。当然，我主要记得的是你。
I have a vivid memory of being on the playground behind my elementary school, trying to explain to the other kids that, the night before, my brother was this big star. And I imitated you, singing the same song, which, of course, I had heard endlessly with you rehearsing it.
我至今记得在小学校园的操场上，试图向其他孩子解释，昨晚我弟弟是个大明星。我模仿你唱歌，那首歌，我因为听你反复排练，当然已经听得烂熟于心。
And I still know the song. And I went out and bought the record, by the way, about five years ago. And I have it. And the only reason I know that album is because of you.
我现在还会唱那首歌。顺便说一下，五年前我买了那张唱片。我有这张碟。我了解那张专辑完全是因为你。
But, I remember, I was imitating you complete with undoing my shirt. I felt like a celebrity, even though the other kids didn't know it, because, god, my brother, he just did this thing. And so I was pretty impressed.
但我记得我当时模仿你，甚至连解开衬衫的动作都做了。我感觉自己像个名人，尽管其他孩子不知道，因为，天呐，我弟弟刚才做到了那个，所以我深受震撼。
If it's not clear by now, I idolized my brother. I used to sneak into his room when he wasn't home and look through his things, put on his clothes, smell his cologne. As a matter of fact, I still have a YMCA T-shirt that he used to wear when he was a counselor at Camp Beaver. It's full of holes, almost a rag, but I'd never let it go.
如果现在还不清楚，我曾崇拜我弟弟。他不在家时，我会偷偷溜进他的房间，翻看他的东西，穿他的衣服，闻他的香水。事实上，我至今还留着一件YMCA的T恤，他当河狸夏令营辅导员时穿的。上面满是洞，几乎成了抹布，但我绝不丢弃。
And I've always followed his career in music because I was sure, especially after high school, that he was going to make the big-time. And he almost did. His close calls with fame were many.
我一直关注他的音乐生涯，因为我确信，尤其在高中毕业后，他会出人头地的。他也确实差点成功了。他与名声擦肩而过的次数很多。
They proceeded to tell us that they were going to put something like a half a million dollars behind The Super Group. And we were going to be the next Beatles or Monkeys. And I think, at the time, I was 21, I believe. And I'm just sitting there going, "Wow. I made the big-time."
他们接着告诉我们，他们要在“超级乐队”身上投入大约50万美元。我们将成为下一个披头士或顽童乐队。当时我好像21岁。我坐在那儿想：“哇。我终于成功了。”
And he actually said to me that, "I think you're the next Bruce Springsteen." He, at the time, was an A&R representative for Atlantic Records.
他实际上对我说：“我觉得你是下一个布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀。”他当时是大西洋唱片的A&R代表。
Joining this band called, Easy Action.
加入那个叫“Easy Action”的乐队。
They said, "Listen, we want 50% of you." And I said, "Forget it." I started a band right after that called Alex Space and the Orbits.
他们说：“听着，我们要你50%的份额。”我说：“想都别想。”在那之后，我马上组建了一个乐队，叫“亚历克斯空间与轨道”。
"We're going to take you to the top."
“我们要把你送上巅峰。”
I moved to another band now, called Flyer.
我现在转到了另一个叫“Flyer”的乐队。
And we had a band called Future City.
我们还有个乐队叫“未来之城”。
That band was called Zippers Polite and the Ambassadors of Love.
那个乐队叫“拉链礼貌与爱的大使”。
It came to the point where every record company thought that the other record company was going to sign me. And, in effect, that I was going to be the next big thing. There were articles written saying that I was going to be the next Kiss, and this, and that. And Warner Brothers, they were going to have cartoons. And even where they were talking about designing some sort of video pinball game, a real total marketing thing.
到了后来，每家唱片公司都以为对方会签下我。实际上，我即将成为下一个大红大紫的明星。当时报纸上写着我将成为下一个Kiss乐队，云云。华纳兄弟甚至考虑要做卡通片。他们甚至讨论过设计某种视频弹球游戏，完全是商业营销那一套。
And I was so excited. And we were a couple of weeks away from signing the contract when OPEC had a oil embargo in 1979. The price of plastic went up 400%. And that was the end of my shot right there. It just vanished before my eyes.
我当时兴奋极了。我们离签署合同只有几周时间了，结果1979年爆发了OPEC石油危机。塑料价格上涨了400%。我的机会在那一刻直接终结了。它就在我眼前消失了。
We ended up getting them to sign us up for a booking contract. And then, one night, they came up to us. And neither of these guys drank. They had ulcers. And they both walked around drinking a glass of milk. I remember, one day, they both walked up to me with a glass of milk, and they said, "Would you mind wearing an Elvis mask?"
我们最后还是让他们签下了一个预订合同。有一天晚上，他们来找我们。这两人都不喝酒。他们都有溃疡。他们俩整天拿着一杯牛奶走来走去。我记得有一天，他们俩拿着牛奶走到我面前，说：“你介意戴个猫王的面具吗？”
To make a long story short, the thing really kind of fell apart. And, at this point, I really got just totally discouraged with the whole scene. And, in fact, I remember just feeling like that what I really had inside me wasn't coming out. And I took this microphone-- I still have it to this day-- and I threw it up against the wall. I don't know. It's all smashed in. I just left and never went back. I left everything I had that was related to music in that room, and just, basically, quit.
长话短说，事情真的搞砸了。在那一刻，我对整个圈子彻底灰心了。事实上，我记得我感觉自己真正想表达的东西没能出来。我拿起麦克风——我至今还留着它——把它砸向了墙。我不知道。它完全变形了。我离开了，再没回头。我把所有和音乐有关的东西都留在了那个房间，基本上就放弃了。
My brother left music completely for many years after this time, around 1984. For a while he dabbled with a little home recording setup trying to write some songs, but his heart wasn't in it. He stopped going out to clubs, lost touch with most of his musician friends, didn't play, didn't perform, just left. Then, in 1991, seven years later, he discovered karaoke.
在那之后，大约从1984年起，我弟弟多年来完全离开了音乐。有一段时间，他尝试过一点家庭录音设备，试图写几首歌，但他已无心于此。他不再去夜店，和大多数音乐朋友断了联系，不演奏，不表演，就那样离开了。然后，在1991年，七年后，他发现了卡拉OK。
I was sitting having dinner. And I heard this music in the lounge. And this chorus of women singing was beautiful. I said, "I have to go in and hear this group." And I went in there, and there's no group. There's a guy who looks like he's sitting behind a keyboard. And he's got this big thing saying, "You are the star. "Sing the hits", or something like that.
我当时在吃晚饭。我听到休息室里有音乐。一群女性在唱合唱，美极了。我说：“我得进去听听这个团体。”我进去后，根本没什么团体。只有一个男的坐在键盘后面。他前面有个大牌子写着：“你是明星。‘唱响金曲’，或者类似的字样。”
And I'm looking up. And there's a video playing of follow the bouncing ball. I didn't know anything about karaoke. And it just sounds fantastic. And I'm saying, "Jeez, all these years I've been sitting around trying to wait for the drummer to show up, or the bass player's having a nervous breakdown. And here there's no band, they just have these laser disks. They play the music and you just go up and sing. Not only that, you don't even have to remember the words because they're showing you the words. They had a little monitor that faces up to you. I mean, this was a singer's delight. It was heaven.
我抬头看。上面播放着跟着跳动圆点唱歌的视频。我对卡拉OK一无所知。这听起来太美妙了。我说：“天哪，这些年来我一直坐在那儿等着鼓手出现，或者是贝斯手崩溃，而这里根本不需要乐队，他们只有激光唱片。他们放音乐，你就上去唱。不仅如此，你甚至不需要背歌词，因为他们把歌词显示给你。他们有一个对着你的小屏幕。我的意思是，这简直是歌手的天堂。太棒了。”
After that, he was hooked.
在那之后，他彻底迷上了。
At the height of my interest in karaoke, easily, I was going out all seven nights.
在我对卡拉OK最狂热的时候，我一周七天都在外面唱。
People loved him. He'd steal the show, knocking out the audience at bars all over the Boston area. And he began winning contests.
人们很喜欢他。他会抢尽风头，征服波士顿各处的酒吧观众。他开始赢得比赛。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
All right, just take it. All right, just leave it right there. We have our five finalists standing over by the video monitor. And, Billy Costa, all four judges have assembled and decided who the winner is going to be. Why don't you tell us who that is.
好的，接过去。好的，就留在那里。五名决赛选手正站在显示器旁。比利·科斯塔，四名评委已经集合完毕，决定了谁是赢家。你告诉我们是谁吧。
Wait a minute. OK, I'll just do it through this. I think it was unanimous. The guy was spectacular, Alex Jones.
等等。好吧，我就直接宣布吧。我想全票通过。这人简直绝了，亚历克斯·琼斯。
Alex Jones!
亚历克斯·琼斯！
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[MUSIC PLAYING - "FALL IN LOVE" BY TOM JONES]
[音乐播放 - 汤姆·琼斯版的《陷入爱河》]
How about a hand for our talented and fabulous Alex Jones, folks!
为我们才华横溢、超级棒的亚历克斯·琼斯鼓掌，各位！
My brother had found his way back to music. But, this time, he was Tom Jones.
我弟弟找到了回归音乐的道路。只不过，这一次，他是汤姆·琼斯。
I feel authentic. I feel real. This is real.
我觉得很地道。我觉得很真实。这就是真实。
So where are you at in your process here?
你这套流程进行到哪一步了？
I like to put the leather pants on because it just feels good. But I forgot one thing. I've got to put something in my pouch. The ladies love this. You've got to roll it up so it's just about that thick, and then you fold it over, OK?
我喜欢穿上皮裤，因为感觉很棒。但我忘了一件事。我得往裤裆里塞点东西。女士们喜欢这个。你得把它卷起来，大概这么厚，然后折叠一下，OK？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
And what you got there is a real peach.
塞进去之后效果简直绝了。
So now you're going to stuff this down the front of your leather pants?
所以你现在要把这个塞进皮裤前面？
Absolutely.
当然。
And this is for the?
这是为了？
Authenticity's sake. The next thing I do is I put a couple of belts with lots of metal on them because it just feels good. [LAUGHS] It also keeps my pants up. OK, now I have to get the makeup on.
为了真实感。接下来的事是戴上几条带有金属扣的腰带，因为感觉很好。[笑声]还能帮我提着裤子。好了，现在得化上妆。
OK. Can I follow you?
OK。我可以跟着你吗？
Oh, absolutely.
噢，当然。
OK.
OK。
Absolutely. I don't have the ruffled shirts. They're all at the cleaners. Yeah, I don't have time to pick up another, so that's the best I can do. It's kind of got that look a bit. See? That's what I have under. But over, as I'll show you later, I have a nice sequined tux that I put over all of this. And I kind of take a couple of things off.
当然。我没有荷叶边衬衫。都在干洗店呢。是啊，我没时间去拿另一件，所以这就是我能做到的最好效果了。看起来还有点那个味儿。你看？这就是我里面穿的。但外面，我一会儿会给你看，我有一件亮片燕尾服，盖在这一切上面。我会脱掉几件东西。
I see, OK.
明白了，OK。
Because I get real hot, you know what I mean? OK, got to have rings and bangles and bongles. I got the big cross because he always had the big cross. So now what I have to do first is tie up me own hair. Oh, I forgot. Also got to put the mascara on the chest hair.
因为我演出时会非常热，你知道我意思吗？好了，还得戴上戒指、手镯和饰品。我戴上那枚大十字架，因为他总带着大十字架。现在首先要做的是把我的头发扎起来。噢，我忘了。还得在胸毛上涂上睫毛膏。
When he was done, my brother was transformed. Not exactly Tom Jones, but close enough and ready to go.
当他弄完时，我弟弟已经彻底变身了。虽然不完全是汤姆·琼斯，但也足够像样，随时准备上台。
Five minutes late ain't no problem when Tom Jones is in the house.
当汤姆·琼斯在场时，晚到五分钟根本不是问题。
[APPLAUSE] Yeah! [WHOOPS]
[掌声] 是的！[起哄声]
Thank you.
谢谢。
My brother and I go to a gig outside Boston where some company's holding its employee appreciation party.
我和我弟弟去了波士顿郊外的一场演出，一家公司正在举行员工答谢聚会。
Any pussycats out there? Do I hear any meows?
有猫咪在吗？我能听到猫叫吗？
It's in a function room next to a hotel restaurant, Bumbershoot's, Rockingham's, or something like that.
是在酒店餐厅旁边的一个功能厅里。
Oh, yeah. Meow. Yes.
噢，是的。喵。是的。
[SINGING  - "WHAT'S NEW PUSSYCAT?" AS TOM JONES]
[演唱 - 作为汤姆·琼斯的《What's New Pussycat?》]
The night before this, my brother told me, he'd performed at a Chinese restaurant. And after his finale, the whole place, all the guests and the waiters, even the stagehands, they all stood up and gave him a standing ovation. He said it was like being in a movie.
在这场演出前一天，我弟弟告诉我，他在一家中餐馆表演过。在那之后，整个地方，所有的客人们和侍者，甚至台下的工作人员，全都起立，给了他热烈的掌声。他说那感觉就像在电影里一样。
[SINGING- "WITHOUT LOVE" AS TOM JONES]
[演唱 - 作为汤姆·琼斯的《Without Love》]
A few months after I interviewed him, my brother got laid off from his computer job. My parents told me they were pretty worried about him. Now he's playing the stock market, trying to parlay his retirement money into a nest egg that will carry him for a while until he makes it big with his Tom Jones act.
在我采访他几个月后，我弟弟的电脑工作被裁了。我父母告诉我他们很为他担心。现在他开始炒股，试图把养老金翻倍，积攒一笔能支撑他一阵子的钱，直到他凭借汤姆·琼斯的表演大红大紫。
While my brother performed, I circulated through the room talking to people.
在我弟弟表演时，我在房间里走动，和人们交谈。
Yeah, this guy is just very good. He's very good.
是的，这家伙真的非常棒。他太棒了。
He's pretty close?
他很像吗？
I thought he was very close. If I didn't meet him in the hallway and know otherwise, I would have questioned was this really the Tom Jones?
我觉得他太像了。如果我不是在走廊遇见他，知道真相，我会怀疑这到底是不是真的汤姆·琼斯。
I didn't tell anyone that Alex Jones was my brother. I just asked them what they thought of him.
我没告诉任何人亚历克斯·琼斯是我弟弟。我只是问他们觉得他怎么样。
He's got a great voice, a really great voice. He does. He's good.
他嗓音很棒，真的太棒了。他是很好。
So how do you get him, anyway?
那么怎么能找到他呢？
I can make sure that he gives you his card.
我可以让他给你一张名片。
Yeah, I would. I'd like to have his card.
是啊，我会的。我想要他的名片。
I wanted to hear that he was making them happy. I wanted him to succeed. I wanted to help him get more work. I wanted to hear that they loved him.
我想听到的就是他让他们感到了快乐。我想让他成功。我想帮他获得更多工作机会。我想听到他们爱戴他。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "FALL IN LOVE" ALEX JONES SINGING TOM JONES]
[音乐播放 - 亚历克斯·琼斯演唱的《陷入爱河》]
Dan Gediman's story about his brother was produced by Jay Allison with consulting producer Christina Eckhoff. And it comes from Jay's series, Life Stories , which was produced with funds from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting and the National Endowment for the Arts.
丹·盖迪曼关于他弟弟的故事由杰·艾利森制作，克里斯蒂娜·埃克霍夫担任咨询制作人。它出自杰的系列节目《人生故事》，该系列由公共广播公司和国家艺术基金会共同资助。
Dan and Jay are currently working on an upcoming series for NPR called, This I Believe . Their website for that, thisibelieve.org. Alex Jones can be hired to work as Tom Jones at private parties and corporate events, but he's working on a CD of his own music under the name Alex Space Jones.
丹和杰目前正在为NPR制作一个即将推出的系列节目，叫《我的信仰》。他们的网站是thisibelieve.org。亚历克斯·琼斯可以被聘请在私人聚会和公司活动中表演汤姆·琼斯，但他目前正以“亚历克斯·空间·琼斯”的名字制作一张属于自己的音乐CD。
Coming up, other strategies to keep music in your life, if traditional music careers don't fly, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，如果传统的音乐职业道路走不通，还有哪些保持音乐活力的策略？当我们的节目继续时，请收听来自芝加哥公共广播电台和国际公共广播电台的报道。
It's This American Life, I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program we choose a theme and bring you a wide variety of stories, documentaries, radio monologues, reportage, found tapes and found documents, which is what I have right here in front of me. Our theme today, stories about people who you could say this about.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周我们都会在节目中选择一个主题，带给你们各种各样的故事、纪录片、广播独白、报道、找到的磁带和文献。这就是我面前的东西。我们今天的主题是关于那些可以被形容为这样的人们的故事。
When you talk about music, your face becomes beautiful.
当你谈论音乐时，你的脸变得很美。
Aha. And, of course, not everybody agrees about this beauty. Some people do not find it touching or inspiring to see people who love music. In fact, there are people who believe that loving music is a crisis of global proportions.
啊哈。当然，并非每个人都认同这种美。有些人并不觉得看到热爱音乐的人会感到触动或启发。事实上，有些人认为热爱音乐是一场全球性危机。
And the document I hold in my hands is an advertisement, a call to arms really, from Motorbooty, a zine, a pretty great zine. And it's an advertisement for the First Annual Conference on World Band Population, on stopping the crisis of world band overpopulation, specifically.
我手中的文献是一则广告，一份真正的战斗檄文，来自一本很棒的杂志《Motorbooty》。这是第一届世界乐队人口统计会议的广告，专门针对如何阻止世界乐队人口过剩的危机。
Says this ad, "According to recent studies, by the year 2001 there will be more people in bands than the global economy can ever hope to support. The US Census Bureau puts the current number of audience members to band members at a ratio of 2:1. The present trends threatened to reverse this relationship, disrupting the delicate balance between performers and normal people. Soon, not only will virtually everyone be in a band, but everyone in a band will be involved in several side projects, creating a glut of virtually indistinguishable groups of guitar-wielding miscreants who, when not performing their so-called music, will be endlessly talking about it to anyone unable to flee."
这则广告写道：“根据最新研究，到2001年，从事乐队工作的人数将超过全球经济所能支撑的极限。美国人口普查局目前的观众与乐队成员比例为2:1。当前趋势威胁要逆转这一比例，破坏表演者与普通人之间的脆弱平衡。很快，不仅几乎每个人都会身处某支乐队，而且每个人都会参与好几个副业项目，制造出一大堆几乎无法区分的、挥舞着吉他的败类组合。当他们不在表演所谓的音乐时，他们会无休止地向任何无法逃脱的人谈论音乐。”
And then the ad explains what's going to happen at the conference. The seminars dealing with the imminent dangers of band overpopulation, Legal Strategies for Achieving Zero Band Population Growth, Private Sector Initiatives for Ending Band Growth, Strategies for Ending Multiple Band Membership.
广告随后解释了会议的内容。有关乐队人口过剩迫在眉睫的研讨会、实现零乐队人口增长的法律策略、结束乐队增长的私营部门举措、结束多个乐队成员身份的策略。
Here's some of the things that they suggest can be done to combat this global crisis, let's see, three-strikes-and-you're-out rules; creating stiff criminal penalties for artists who release more than three full-length albums per career; waiting periods for instrument purchasers to allow for mandatory background checks for prior infractions, and a cooling-off period to discourage thoughtless and impulsive band formation; stiff fines for bands that imitate other bands; civil infractions for air bands, and an all-out ban on cover bands.
以下是他们建议采取的应对全球危机的措施，让我们看看：三振出局规则；为发行超过三张全长专辑的艺术家制定严厉的刑事处罚；为购买乐器者设定等待期，以便进行强制性的违规行为背景调查，并设定冷静期以遏制轻率和冲动的组队行为；对模仿其他乐队的乐队课以重罚；对“空气乐队”处以民事罚款，并全面禁止翻唱乐队。
They also suggest-- let's see-- boycotting labels that refuse to stop signing additional bands as well as cracking down on pointless, local, so-called, indie labels; finally, supporting random band testing by employers, especially in high-risk businesses like coffee shops, copy shops, cafes, bars, and record stores.
他们还建议——看看——抵制拒绝停止签约额外乐队的厂牌，并打击毫无意义的、所谓的当地独立厂牌；最后，支持雇主对乐队成员进行随机测试，特别是在咖啡馆、打印店、餐厅、酒吧和唱片店等高风险企业。
Well, given the crisis of global band population explosion, perhaps the only honorable course for all of us is to forget about performing and just put that energy into being members of the audience. And what we present next on our program, as Act Three, is a case example of how to do exactly that.
好吧，鉴于全球乐队人口爆炸的危机，或许我们所有人唯一光荣的路就是忘记表演，把精力投入到成为观众成员中。而我们接下来在节目中作为第三幕呈现的，正是如何做到这一点的一个案例。
This is the Fastbacks, a pop, punk band from Seattle that's been around for years, actually. And the story you're about to hear is not about being in a semi-obscure but well-respected band, it's about being a fan of a semi-obscure but well-respected band. Sarah Vowell is a writer and a music columnist for the San Francisco Weekly , and she tells the story.
这是西雅图的一支流行朋克乐队，名叫“Fastbacks”，他们已经存在很多年了。你们即将听到的故事不是关于身处一支半冷门但备受尊敬的乐队，而是关于成为一支半冷门但备受尊敬的乐队的粉丝。萨拉·沃威尔是一位作家，也是《旧金山周刊》的音乐专栏作家，她讲述了这个故事。
Sometimes, opening your mail can be a little like listening to the radio. You're not paying attention, just absent-mindedly flipping through the letters and bills, and then, wham, some little surprise comes out of nowhere and changes your day.
有时候，拆开信件有点像听广播。你没注意，只是心不在焉地翻看着信件和账单，然后，砰，一些小惊喜突然出现，改变了你的一天。
I got this package. Inside was a letter, thanking me for mentioning the Fastbacks in a book review I had written, not from one of the Fastbacks themselves, mind you, just some guy in Chicago. His name was Scott Lee, and he'd enclosed this xerox booklet about the band.
我收到了这个包裹。里面有一封信，感谢我在书评中提到了Fastbacks，不是来自乐队成员本人，只是芝加哥的一个家伙。他叫斯科特·李，还附上了一本关于乐队的影印小册子。
Flipping through it, I stopped cold at something called, "The Fastback's Drummers Pie Chart". Since they formed in 1979, the Fastbacks have gone through about a dozen drummers. And this pie chart identifies the drummers by name, listing the percentage of songs which each one has contributed to. But, at the bottom of the page, small print warns, "Note, Rusty and Nate's shares may not be totally accurate. Their percentages may be approximately 0.68% off." And I don't think a decimal point had ever struck me as endearing before. The drastic exactitude of 0.68% sort of captured my heart, and I had to meet this person.
翻看时，我在一个叫“Fastbacks鼓手饼图”的地方停住了。自1979年组建以来，Fastbacks已经换了十几位鼓手。这个饼图按名字列出了鼓手，列出了每位鼓手贡献歌曲的百分比。但在页面底部，小字警示道：“注：拉斯蒂和内特的份额可能不完全准确。他们的百分比可能误差约0.68%。”我不认为小数点点位曾经让我觉得如此可爱。那种0.68%的严谨简直俘获了我的心，我必须见见这个人。
Basically, it has your standard discography. And then there's just some facts here that I dug out, 139 total songs, eight hours, 25 minutes, 43 seconds worth of songs.
基本上，它有标准的唱片目录。还有一些我挖出来的统计数据，总共139首歌，八小时、25分、43秒的音乐总量。
So he showed me other stats, like total recorded versions of songs, total number of seconds of songs, which is 30,343, in case you were wondering.
所以他向我展示了其他数据，比如总共录制的版本数，歌曲总秒数，如果你好奇的话，是30,343秒。
--shortest song, shortest instrumental song, shortest song with vocals, the longest song, and the longest song without a drum solo. That's only because--
——最短的歌，最短的器乐歌曲，最短的带人声歌曲，最长的歌，以及最长的不带鼓独奏的歌。这只是因为——
I was stunned. I mean, I thought I liked the band. And, normally, as a music lover and as a woman, I rail against the mostly-male, record-collector geek habit of reducing rock and roll to baseball card collecting. They flatten out this complex, thrilling thing down to manageable lists of names and titles and dates.
我惊呆了。我是说，我以为我喜欢这支乐队。通常情况下，作为一个音乐爱好者和女性，我反感那种以男性为主的唱片收集怪癖，他们把摇滚乐简化为收集棒球卡。他们把这种复杂、令人兴奋的东西压平为可管理的姓名、标题和日期列表。
But Scott Lee's Fastbacks tribute has the devotional fervour of a medieval illuminated manuscript. The list of facts and figures is so relentless and exact and painstaking that it takes on this liturgical glow, as if the Fastbacks were a religion and Scott Lee its prophet.
但斯科特·李对Fastbacks的致敬却有一种中世纪泥金手抄本般的虔诚。这些事实和数据列得如此无情、严谨且呕心沥血，以至于它带上了一种礼仪般的光辉，仿佛Fastbacks是一种宗教，而斯科特·李就是先知。
But some of the new additions to this-- as I ramble here-- listed out the songs A through Z and did the percentages of songs starting with each letter. And the letter that won was I. There were 19 Fastback songs that started with I, representing about 14% of the songs. With every album, they seem to have a song that starts with, "In", like, "In America", "In The Summer", "In The Winter", "In The Observatory".
但其中一些新的补充——当我在这儿闲谈时——列出了从A到Z的歌曲，并统计了每个字母开头的歌曲百分比。胜出的字母是I。Fastbacks有19首歌以I开头，占歌曲总数的14%左右。每张专辑，他们似乎都有以“In”开头的歌，比如“In America”、“In The Summer”、“In The Winter”、“In The Observatory”。
I soon found out that the band has befriended Scott Lee and that they've sort of informally appointed him their de-facto archivist. Singer Kim Warnick corresponds with Scott via email, sometimes, like four times a day. Guitarist and songwriter, Kurt Bloch, graciously calls him "A good person to have on our team." Though, when he first saw Scott Lee's packet, he had some understandable worries.
我很快发现乐队已经和斯科特·李交了朋友，他们已经非正式地任命他为事实上的档案管理员。歌手金·沃尼克有时通过电子邮件与斯科特沟通，甚至每天四次。吉他手兼词曲作者库尔特·布洛赫优雅地称他为“我们团队里很好的人”。不过，当他第一次看到斯科特·李的资料包时，他有一些可以理解的担忧。
Ah! I mean, it was like, boy. The first thing that would come to my mind is, is this guy really scary? Is he the kind of person I would run away from, if he was ever in the same room? Is this the kind of person that I would stop answering my telephone if he called? And, no, it's not. Not to make you think that we don't think Scott Lee is actually fairly crazy of a person, but he's not the annoying kind of crazy person that you read about. And I think he appreciates his own over-the-top-ness.
啊！我的意思是，当时的想法是，天呐。我脑子里冒出的第一件事是，这家伙真的可怕吗？如果他出现在同一个房间里，他会是我那种想逃跑的人吗？如果他打电话，我会拒绝接听吗？不，不是。并不是说我不觉得斯科特·李本人相当疯狂，但他不是那种你在新闻里读到的那种令人讨厌的疯狂。而且我觉得他自己也意识到了这种过火。
If anything, the Fastbacks are a little protective of Scott Lee. When I was talking to Kurt, I jokingly called Scott his stalker. But he set me straight.
如果有的话，Fastbacks对斯科特·李还有点保护欲。当我和库尔特谈话时，我开玩笑地称斯科特为他的跟踪狂。但他纠正了我。
No, he's not a stalker. He's a super-fan.
不，他不是跟踪狂。他是超级粉丝。
Oh, a super-fan?
噢，超级粉丝？
Yeah. Stalker, that has negative connotations. Yeah, that's something we don't need. Super-fan is fine.
是的。跟踪狂有消极含义。是的，那是不必要的。超级粉丝很好。
Like the super-fan, the members of the Fastbacks all have day jobs. So, on any given day, it's possible that Scott is devoting more energy to being a fan than the Fastbacks devote to being in the band. When I interviewed Kim, the gaping differences between being a band member and being a super-fan were never clearer.
像这位超级粉丝一样，Fastbacks的成员都有白天的工作。所以，在任何一天，斯科特投入作为粉丝的精力可能比Fastbacks投入乐队的时间还要多。当我采访金时，身为乐队成员和超级粉丝之间的巨大差异从未如此清晰。
OK, so I have a pop-quiz for you.
OK，我要考你一个快问快答。
OK.
OK。
How many total songs, before the new album, New Mansions in Sound , have the Fastbacks recorded?
在新专辑《New Mansions in Sound》之前，Fastbacks总共录制了多少首歌？
What is it, now?
现在是多少来着？
How many total songs have the Fastbacks recorded?
Fastbacks总共录制了多少首歌？
Well, you know, unfortunately, I don't have something in front of me that could answer that question.
好吧，不幸的是，我手头没有能回答那个问题的资料。
Really? OK. I have to say it is 127. And I was wondering also if you knew the median song length?
真的？好吧。我得说那是127首。我还想知道你是否知道中位数时长？
The what?
什么？
Well, let's start with an easier one. What do you think is the average length of a Fastbacks song?
好吧，从简单的开始吧。你觉得Fastbacks歌曲的平均长度是多少？
She doesn't know. But, according to Scott, it's two minutes, 51 seconds.
她不知道。但根据斯科特的数据，是两分51秒。
When I visit Scott Lee's house on Chicago's north side, his roommate lets me in. Scott's playing his guitar along with the new Fastbacks album. His room is decorated with Fastbacks posters. And Scott himself wears a Fastbacks T-shirt. He shows me this incredibly complex chart he's working on, a sort of family tree to the Seattle music scene, a town, by the way, which he has only visited once.
当我造访斯科特·李位于芝加哥北区的房子时，他的室友让我进去了。斯科特正跟着Fastbacks的新专辑弹吉他。他的房间装饰着Fastbacks的海报。斯科特本人穿着Fastbacks的T恤。他向我展示了他正在研究的极其复杂的图表，一种西雅图音乐场景的家谱，顺便提一下，那个城市他只去过一次。
The producers of This American Life would like me to say here that, when Scott talks about the Fastbacks, he becomes beautiful because that would go along with the first piece in the show today. But I would never say something so corny.
《美国生活》的制作人希望我在这里说，当斯科特谈论Fastbacks时，他的脸变得很美，因为这会呼应今天节目中的第一部分。但我绝不会说出如此老套的话。
When do you think you made the switch between just being a listener and being, as Kurt Bloch called you today, a super-fan?
你觉得你是在什么时候从一个普通的听众变成了库尔特·布洛赫今天所说的“超级粉丝”？
I think the transition really happened when I was in law school, and I had made this tape of my favorite Fastbacks songs. And I was walking across a very icy, cold midway in Buffalo. And, despite how cold it was, when I listened to this music, it really just pumped all this life into me. It was really a life-affirming experience, as corny as that might sound. But, I don't know, I was just really happy at that point. And it was just a light on me that shown. And I hadn't seen it before. And now everything seemed better.
我觉得那个转变真的发生在我读法学院的时候，当时我制作了一盘我最喜欢的Fastbacks歌曲的磁带。我正走过布法罗一个冰冷刺骨的中途站。尽管天气很冷，但当我听这音乐时，它真的给我的生命注入了活力。这真的是一次肯定生命的经历，听起来可能很老套。但我不知道，在那一刻我真的非常快乐。在那之前我从未见过那样的光亮，而现在，一切似乎都变得更好了。
When you show this info packet to people, what is usually their reaction?
当你把这个资料包展示给人们时，他们的反应通常是什么？
I think the first question I always hear is, "Do you have a lot of spare time?"
我想我听到的第一个问题总是：“你有很多闲暇时间吗？”
In fact, Scott's spare time is limited. He holds down a full-time job at a Chicago advertising agency, and he writes his own songs. And, truthfully, he flirts with the idea of not staying a fan. He's moving to Seattle, partly to be closer to the Fastbacks. He's actually in their circle of friends now. And he's tried a couple of times to start his own band.
事实上，斯科特的闲暇时间很有限。他在芝加哥的一家广告代理公司有一份全职工作，而且他自己也在写歌。说实话，他曾动过不再做粉丝的念头。他正要搬到西雅图，部分原因是为了离Fastbacks更近。他现在确实在他们的朋友圈里了。而且他试过几次想组建自己的乐队。
Once, he was invited on-stage with Kurt to play along with the song. It was exciting. But he's left-handed. And they didn't have a left-handed guitar for him. So it was sort of a disaster, not the moment a super-fan dreams of.
有一次，他被库尔特邀请上台一起演奏。这很令人激动。但他是个左撇子。而他们没有左手吉他给他。所以这算是场灾难，不是那种超级粉丝梦想中的时刻。
So, in this show, what happens is someone tells their little story and then we play a song. So you get to pick which Fastbacks song gets to play at the end of your story.
所以，在这个节目里，通常会发生的事是某人讲述他们的小故事，然后我们播放一首歌。所以你可以选择最后在你故事结尾播放哪首Fastbacks的歌。
At the end of my story? Whew. [LAUGHS] I'd probably say, "Save Room For Me", then. Because I've definitely saved room for the Fastbacks, so, "Save Room For Me".
在我故事结尾？呼。[笑声]那我可能会说《Save Room For Me》（为我留个位置）。因为我确实为Fastbacks留出了位置，所以是《Save Room For Me》。
[MUSIC PLAYING - "SAVE ROOM FOR ME" BY FASTBACKS]
[音乐播放 - Fastbacks的《Save Room For Me》]
Sarah Vowell, our contributing editor and the voice of teenage superhero, Violet Parr, in Pixar's new movie, The Incredibles.
萨拉·沃威尔，我们的特约编辑，皮克斯新片《超人总动员》中青少年超级英雄维奥莱特·帕尔的配音演员。
Act Four, A Life in Music. Sam Franco's 72 and has spent his life playing and teaching the accordion. And the thing to know about him is he hates accordion music, most of it, anyway.
第四幕，音乐人生。萨姆·弗兰科72岁了，一生都在弹奏和教授手风琴。关于他，需要知道的一点是，他讨厌手风琴音乐，或者说大部分都讨厌。
The sound of the accordion, we don't associate ourselves with too much, is like this.
我们通常联想到的手风琴声音是这样的。
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
See? I haven't done that for years. It's hard for me to even play a regular style.
你看？我已经很多年没那样弹过了。我甚至很难按常规风格演奏。
I see why you like it the other way.
我明白你为什么喜欢另一种弹法了。
Well, the other way it swings. [LAUGHS] It swings with the one finger. And I get a jazz sound, like this. Watch.
好吧，另一种弹法更有摇摆感。[笑声]那种风格是用一个手指弹奏的。我能弹出一种爵士乐的声音，像这样。看着。
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
Sam Franco hates that accordion oom-pah beat. He doesn't like the normal Lawrence Welk chord progressions. In his music, he changes them into jazz chord progressions. And, where normal accordion players use lots of chords all over the place, he prefers to play single notes. In his head, when he plays, Sam hears Coleman Hawkins and other jazz greats. He invented this style. And, if you check the Chicago Yellow Pages for jazz accordion, Sam is the only listing.
萨姆·弗兰科讨厌那种手风琴的“砰-啪”节奏。他不喜欢那种常规的劳伦斯·威尔克式的和弦走向。在他的音乐里，他把它改成了爵士和弦走向。而且，普通手风琴手喜欢到处使用和弦，但他更喜欢弹奏单音。在演奏时，萨姆脑子里听到的全是科尔曼·霍金斯和其他爵士大师的声音。他发明了这种风格。如果你查看芝加哥黄页上的爵士手风琴，萨姆是唯一的条目。
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
All this hour we've heard from people who want to make their living, full-time, from their music. They dream and strive for that. Sam's done it all his life, playing gigs, working, never getting famous, though.
这一小时我们听到的都是那些想靠音乐全职谋生的人。他们为此梦想和奋斗。萨姆一生都在做这个，演出、工作，但他从未出名。
You know what saved me? That I had the knack for teaching. You understand? That was my ace-in-the-hole, would be the teaching part. If I didn't have that, I would be out of the music business completely.
你知道什么救了我吗？我有教书的天赋。你明白吗？那是我的王牌，教书那部分。如果没那个，我早就彻底退出音乐行业了。
He's watched players who weren't any better than him get a lot of attention, get notoriety, get more gigs. And, in the end, he decided he doesn't care. That life doesn't suit him.
他看着那些水平不如他的人得到了很多关注、声望，得到了更多演出。最终，他决定不在乎了。那种生活不适合他。
You couldn't pay mortgages, buy a house, on playing because you played one night. That's it. How would you like to go look for a job every week? And that's what it amounted to. I never did have that kind of energy.
你无法靠只在那儿演一场就能付房贷、买房子。就是这样。你愿意每周去到处找工作吗？情况就是如此。我从来没有那种精力。
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
Most of the people who Sam started playing with back when he was a kid did not stay with music. Back when Sam began, accordion was huge, huge. Every band in Chicago had an accordionist doing their keyboards because pianos, in those days, were so impractical, you know? You can't carry them around. The one that you find at the hall is always out of tune.
萨姆小时候开始和他一起演奏的大多数人都没有坚持做音乐。萨姆刚开始时，手风琴简直火得不行。芝加哥的每个乐队都有手风琴手来弹键盘部分，因为在那些日子里，钢琴太不方便了，你知道吧？你没法带着它们到处走。礼堂里的那架钢琴总是不准。
But that era did not last. When Elvis hit in the late '50s and rock and roll followed, accordion business died. Nobody hired them. Nobody wanted to take lessons. And lots of guys who Sam played and taught with quit the music business.
但那个时代并没有持续多久。猫王在50年代末走红，摇滚乐随之而来，手风琴行业就死了。没人雇佣他们，没人想学这个。萨姆一起演奏和教书的那些人，很多都退出了音乐圈。
Sam had always played guitar too. And he was actually one of the few people in his crowd who made the jump from the swing era to the rock era. These days, he jokes that every brick of his house was paid for by rock and roll. A big poster of electric guitarist, Randy Rhoads, is the biggest thing in his music room. He taught lessons for years on the guitar. But Sam still views the guitar as an inferior instrument. He can lecture you for a long time on how it's not in the symphony orchestra. Basically, in his view, America's 40-year love affair with the guitar is a concerted effort to slap back at the accordion.
萨姆也一直弹吉他。事实上，他是那帮人里少数几个从摇摆时代跨越到摇滚时代的人。这些天，他开玩笑说他房子的每一块砖都是摇滚乐付钱盖的。一张电吉他手兰迪·罗兹的大海报是他音乐室里最大的东西。他教了多年吉他课。但萨姆仍然认为吉他是低劣的乐器。他可以跟你长篇大论它是怎么进不了交响乐团的。在他看来，美国人这40年来对吉他的痴迷，基本上是一场对手风琴的反叛。
Because everybody's mother and father played the accordion. And they said, we're not going to play it, you know? We're going to play something different. And there it was. It just came out as a rebel cause, I think. It only has five notes, a set of six strings. Two are the same, so it brings it down to five notes, you know? You have to hit it with a pick. You've got to use two hands to make one note. Does that make sense? Why would you want to do that? Why would you want to use two hands to make one note?
因为所有人的爸爸妈妈都拉手风琴。他们说，我们不学那个，你知道吧？我们要弹点不一样的。它就那样出来了，我觉得这是一场反叛。它只有五个音，六根琴弦。两根音一样，所以它只有五个音，你知道吗？你必须用拨片弹。你得用双手去制造一个音。这合理吗？你为什么想那样做？为什么你要用双手去制造一个音呢？
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
I met Sam through one of his students, Catherine Boyd, who totally adores Sam, has known him for years and says that, whatever goes on in Sam's life, he's always happy when he's talking about music.
我通过他的学生凯瑟琳·博伊德认识了萨姆，她非常崇拜萨姆，认识他很多年了，她说无论萨姆的生活里发生什么，当他在谈论音乐时，他总是快乐的。
And the most surprising thing Sam told me when we talked is that it took him a long time before he was completely at peace with the way he plays. He started playing accordion when he was 10. He's 72 now. He played accordions back in the old neighborhood on Taylor Street as a kid. He found his way to the jazz sound that he loves by high school.
萨姆告诉我的最令我惊讶的事是，他花了好长时间才对自己演奏方式彻底安之若素。他10岁开始弹手风琴。他现在72岁。小时候他在泰勒街的老社区里拉手风琴。他在高中时就找到了自己热爱的爵士乐感觉。
He played in USO shows during World War II. He taught and gigged for the next half century. But he says he never felt good about his playing until he was in his '50s. Up until that point, the sound that he heard in his head wasn't what was coming out of the instrument. In his '50s, he said, he just stopped worrying about what people would say about his playing. He just played.
他在二战期间参加过USO演出。接下来的半个世纪他一直在教学和演出。但他说直到50多岁，他才对自己的演奏感到满意。在那之前，他脑子里听到的声音并没有从乐器里传出来。他说，在50多岁时，他不再担心别人会怎么评论他的演奏。他只是演奏。
I'd like to say this, is that I never enjoyed playing as much as I do today. In all my days, I never enjoyed playing as much as I do now. So, why is that? Ask me why.
我想说的是，我从未像今天这样享受弹奏。在我所有岁月里，我从未像现在这样享受音乐。所以，为什么呢？问我为什么。
Why is that?
为什么呢？
Yeah, why is that? Because, today, I know what I can do. I know my limitations, and I know my abilities. Like, if I can't do it, I say who cares, you know? I can do something else. But, when I was younger, I knew my limitations. Of course, we all know our limitations, and that bothers you. But, today, it doesn't bother me.
是的，为什么呢？因为今天，我知道我能做什么。我知道我的局限性，也知道我的能力。比如，如果我做不到，我就说谁在乎呢，你知道吧？我可以做点别的。但我年轻时，我知道自己的局限。当然，我们都知道自己的局限性，那很困扰你。但今天，它不困扰我了。
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
Today, in his music room, surrounded by his instruments, with one of his favorite students, Catherine, egging him on during our interview, Sam couldn't seem happier, really.
今天，在他的音乐室里，被乐器包围着，还有他最喜欢的学生之一凯瑟琳在采访时为他加油，萨姆看起来再开心不过了。
[ACCORDIAN PLAYING]
[手风琴演奏]
Well, our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Peter Clowney and Alix Spiegel.
好吧，我们的节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我本人制作，彼得·克劳尼和阿利克斯·斯皮格尔协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free or buy CDs of them. Or you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife, where they have public radio programs, bestselling books, even The New York Times all at audible.com
我们的网站是www.thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们的节目或购买CD。或者你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载节目的音频，那里有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至是《纽约时报》的内容，网址都是audible.com。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
WBEZ management oversight by Mr. Torey Malatia, who is staring in your eyes right this second when he says--
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他在说出这句话时正凝视着你的眼睛——
When you talk about music, your face becomes beautiful.
当你谈论音乐时，你的脸变得很美。
Yes, it does. And we'll be back in your face next week with more stories of This American Life.
是的，确实如此。下周我们将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回到你面前。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。